this is what some might call the
real-life limitless pill which comes in
this box that costs 400 and i'm going to
try it as well as a bunch of other
powerful brain boosting supplements but
working my way up starting with the
cheapest one this one costs 10 bucks
comes with only two pills
i don't feel it yet on a good day i get
about four hours of really deep focused
concentrated work done if this stuff
could stretch it to five six maybe seven
hours that would change everything these
brain boosting pills also called
nootropics or smart drugs are kind of
like potions in a video game they give
you a short buff that can increase your
concentration memory and overall
immortality and a lot of top performers
in the world are using it to their
advantage and is that the secret why
they accomplish so much all right got a
couple of hours of work done i feel a
little bit of a buzz i want to work out
i think i could take a second
this
was a mistake because as it said on the
packaging this amino acid rich liquid is
the source of the adult hornet's
strength endurance and seemingly
boundless energy
i definitely feel it now i feel like i
can do another personal best in the
squat
your eyes are bugging i think it's the
caffeine i never take caffeine i hope
it's gonna wear off soon i've been
working until just now i think this gave
me a good caffeine boost so this cheap
one has already had these effects what
is the 400 one gonna be like but apart
from that what are the real secrets of
the world's most productive people who
get insane amounts done i've spent
countless hours studying them and there
are three things i've found that they
all have in common and they might
surprise you but first it was time to
try the second one which is called alpha
brain i want an alpha brain so this is
supposed to help with focus and memory
and i'm gonna be taking it with
[Music]
chris
it's from on it the company that joe
rogan owns 50 of supposedly he takes it
before every episode because it helps
him form sentences we're like we're in
like this wave of like if it helps with
memory and focus i hope it doesn't bring
back any suppressed challenges
oh no i've got some planning and writing
to do for the next video let's see
i feel this one a slight buzz like my
senses are heightened and i'm just able
to focus a little bit more how you doing
no super amazing effects sorry joe rogan
so what are the real secrets the first
thing i learned from the most productive
people was a game changer for me in my
first business i decided to sell in all
european countries instead of just
germany because more countries equals
more sales it took months of paperwork i
built systems hired someone to manage it
and finally after six months or so i
added an extra 15 of revenue with almost
no profit if instead i would have
focused on launching more products i
would have doubled my business in six
months and that's when i learned this
lesson that productivity is not about
efficiency it's mostly about
effectiveness just one hour of planning
can save you an entire day an entire
week an entire year even an entire
decade because think of that guy who a
hundred million dollar business for 10
years realizes oh i actually hate my
life i actually want to just live a
simple life and spend time with the
people i love or you could have done
that 10 years ago if you just would have
reflected a little bit more getting more
done is not just about putting in more
hours somebody else is working 50 hours
and you're working 100 you'll get twice
as much done in the course of a year as
uh the other company i mean he's the
billionaire i'm just some you kind of
ruined my point now today we're taking
the new pept and hunter is here i'm a
little bit nervous about it trust me i'm
an expert in this the guy on youtube
said the work ethic goes way up infinite
it basically grows on trees it's very
potent apparently you feel it
immediately what happens if i take this
notice pass out
well do you have health insurance
so i had an idea recently for this
youtube video of like his downfall i was
blind but now i see
avalanches of creative ideas started
flowing into my consciousness
everything would change now
so you're already feeling it right i'm
feeling it yes the tingly sensation that
i'm feeling like yeah when i was
starting to brainstorm i was like man
i'm just like so zoned in when i read
stuff i'll be reading and then i'll zone
out and so i have to go re-read stuff
but right now i'm just zoned in if it
helps you get focused for a few hours a
day and just crank it up more it can
make a big difference next up i tried
qualia which is 140 bucks they smell a
bit fishy i like it and you gotta take
seven capsules in a day i feel good but
most people only notice effects after
taking it consistently for two weeks
which is too much for this video
so before moving on to the 400 nootropic
what's the second secret this second
pattern i've noticed among the most
productive people might be the hardest
one to implement but the results are
exponential see in my circle i see a lot
of entrepreneurs who have a successful
ecommerce business and then they start a
second brand in a different niche and
everyone's making banking crypto so they
spend months studying the latest moon
coin then nfts are popping off so they
have to get in right now and then they
also decide to build a personal brand
because tick tock is currently making
people blow up like crazy and to be fair
they end up having multiple million
dollar businesses that if they put all
of that time and effort into that one
business in the beginning instead of
making a million in consulting crypto
nfts and whatnot they would have a 30
million dollar business right now
because in almost everything growth is
exponential the deeper you go into just
one thing the higher the returns get
they were tempted by all these
low-hanging fruits that made them miss
out on this one gigantic fruit on top of
the tree which is really hard to reach
and you have to ignore all the ones that
are dangling right in front of your face
so the second secret is their disgusting
focus they say no to everything because
nobody has ever changed the world
building five companies at the same time
[Music]
god damn it elon stop maybe this final
nootropic is gonna bring me closer to
elon's real productivity secret it's
here i have big expectations you make
these customer tropics who are your
clients the world's elite the people
that monetize their minds ceos
executives we've got some of the top
actors in hollywood it comes with an app
it says i'm supposed to start with the
nectar x1 3000 experiments i was looking
for a solution to help people get off of
oxycontin and really really hardcore
drugs my wife at the time had become
addicted during the last birth of our
last child they gave her four oxycodone
and she fell in love with it a decade
later she committed suicide on oxycodone
and methadone so that kind of set me on
a route of going okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna resurrect my biochemistry
background and go let's go make this
thing after 3000 we hit on this little
nuanced part of the formula that changed
from being pretty good to very good to
exceptional um to the point where the
the last group of guys on the beta test
said hey that looks that's a lot like
the thing from that bradley cooper movie
world domination here we go
[Music]
tastes a bit like medicine but it tastes
good
damn
i feel good like this calm focus wow
i feel motivated a little stimulated
it's subtle i want to try more of this
take three to eight sprays anytime you
want a boost in your mood start with
three sprays and see how your brain
reacts literally tastes like candy
i think i'm getting a headache maybe we
should wait
yeah yeah
seven pumps is all i need
i really feel it now i was in a pretty
bad head space earlier and now i feel
like i can't be
the next day i wanted to try their
strongest stack for deep work combining
two of their capsules together what are
some other weird hacks that you see
these people use i mean let's just be
honest a lot of nicotine i mean coffee's
in the tropic listen i know people
that know the goat i'm not gonna name
his name does he use things to keep
himself functioning
yeah
i'm going to take focus savagery
together with upbeat just looks like an
evil villain pill i've gone through
pretty much everything focus savagery
and upbeat oh you take those and just
like let's get to work there's an
intensity high performers have that
normal people don't i'm sipping on the
power solution today and it tastes
horrible but it kicks in man some of it
was super helpful for me it's definitely
not for everyone but if you're
interested there's a link in the
description they hooked me up with a
discount code leon so you're 10 off but
for everyone else for the everyday
entrepreneur what are the things that
you would tell them to really optimize
their productivity and their performance
which brings us to the third and biggest
hack there's this story that i read that
drilled it into my mind of this guy who
asked richard branson you know you've
built so many successful companies
what's your secret to being so
productive and richard branson leaned
back and revealed his trick in two words
work out the best advice is always the
boring fundamental stuff sleep diet
exercise nothing beats great sleep that
is the ultimate recovery tool we look
for hacks and tricks and tactics but if
you don't have these three things dialed
in you don't even have the right to
think about other productivity methods
but the most successful people have
these fundamentals dialed in where do
you sleep tonight tonight's in a factory
you sleep in a conference room in the
not finished factory tonight yeah it
gives me a good feel for what's going on
i quit also make sure you check out this
video over here i put a ton of work into
all of them i'm sure you're gonna like
it thanks for watching i'll see you in
the next one